[Music]
hello, how are you, sali jaramillo came out
with his briefing for today, tuesday
, april 13, health experts say
they found three cases of the
brazilian kobe variant in clark county,
the health district calls it
a worrisome variant, one of the  three
people said they received the first
dose of the vaccine against the virus
although none have been hospitalized
this variant has already been detected in several
states it is believed to spread more
easily than the original
snowfall is working to fix
errors on the department's online page
unemployment some
people were unable to apply for their
benefits and may be receiving
error messages the department
said there is no set time to
know when the system will be ready
the hotel circa is looking to hire staff
in various positions they will give interviews
from 9am to 1pm  in the afternoon
to supply 100 jobs,
the main ones are security waitress  d
among others remember that you have to be
over 21 to apply for a job here you
need to fill out the application prior to applying
and now we turn to the
weather forecast a sunny day is expected with a maximum
close to 86 degrees as well as
strong winds will return until
night  Have a nice day I'm
Salí Jaramillo and this was your brief
informative for News Now in Spanish
[Music]